en otros vídeos ya hemos introducido la
idea de solución extraña donde vas a
resolver una ecuación así que te dan una
ecuación original y haces muchos pasos
algebraicos la resuelve si obtienes
algunas soluciones y lo que hemos visto
especialmente cuando estamos tratando
con ecuaciones radicales y especialmente
algunas ecuaciones racionales a veces no
todas las soluciones funcionan para
nuestra ecuación original y así las
soluciones que no funcionan son las que
llamamos extrañas lo que vamos a hacer
en este vídeo es revisar esto con más
detalle vamos a ver algunas soluciones
extrañas pero realmente vamos a pensar
profundamente porque aparecen así que
vamos a dar un ejemplo y este es uno con
el que espero que estés familiarizado o
al menos espero que estés familiarizado
con la idea cuando se trata de
ecuaciones radicales digamos que estás
tratando de resolver 12 x menos 1 es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 8 - x y me
voy a ir rápidamente si esto no te es
familiar te invito a revisar cómo se
resuelven las ecuaciones radicales
pero realmente aquí vamos a estudiar
porque obtenemos una solución extraña
así que pausa este vídeo y trata de
encontrar cuáles son las soluciones te
daré una pista una de ellas va a ser
extraña piensa con cuidado porque
aparece esa solución extraña muy bien
ahora hagámoslo juntos y solo para
avanzar a través de los pasos que hemos
visto antes para ecuaciones radicales
queremos elevar al cuadrado a ambos
lados de modo que si elevamos al
cuadrado el lado izquierdo obtendremos
4x al cuadrado menos 4 x + 1 es igual a
elevado al cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de
8 menos x y vas a obtener sólo 8 menos x
y ahora veamos podemos restar 8 de ambos
lados y podemos sumar x a ambos lados
así que sólo tenemos 0 en el lado
derecho y en el lado izquierdo vamos a
obtener 4x cuadrada menos 13 x 7 es
igual a 0
así que aquí tenemos una ecuación
cuadrática interesante podrías usar la
fórmula cuadrática pero
parece que este podría ser factor y
sable por agrupación sólo tenemos que
pensar en dos números que cuando los
sumamos a b tiene que ser igual a menos
3 y a por b tiene que ser igual a 4 x
menos 7 tiene que ser igual a menos 28 y
los números que son novios parecen estar
justo delante de nosotros 4 y menos 7 4
más menos 7 es igual a menos 34 x menos
7 es igual a menos 28 así que sólo
tenemos que descomponer este menos 13 x
en un 4x y un menos 7 x tekken hacer eso
de modo que tienes 4x al cuadrado y esto
es factorizar por agrupación una vez más
y esto no te es familiar te invito a que
lo revisen khan academy así que vamos a
obtener más 4x menos 7x fíjense que
estos dos suman menos 3x en realidad no
estoy cambiando la ecuación o el valor o
lo que esté tratando de expresar esto es
igual a cero y en la factorización por
agrupación podemos agrup
estos dos juntos y luego podemos agrupar
estos dos juntos y para estos dos
primeros podemos factorizar 4x y así
vamos a obtener 4x por x 1 y en los
siguientes podemos factorizar menos 7
por x 1 y todo eso va a ser igual a 0 y
luego podemos factorizar x 1 de modo que
vamos a obtener x + 1 x 4 x 7 es igual a
0 y una vez más esto es sólo para que
podamos calcular cuáles son las
soluciones así que podemos ver que ya
sea que x + 1 va a ser igual a 0 lo que
sucede cuando x es igual a menos 1 o 4 x
7 es igual a 0 lo que sucede cuando 4x
es igual a 7 lo que sucede cuando x es
igual a 7 cuartos así que tenemos estas
dos soluciones y prometí que una de
ellas sería extraña intentemos primero
esta x es igual a menos 1 y recuerda
cuando resuelves una ecuación radical
como ésta quiere sustituir en la
ecuación
para ver si son extrañas o no entonces
cuando sustituya x es igual a menos 1
vas a obtener 2 x menos uno menos uno es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 8 menos
menos 1 y así en el lado izquierdo
tienes menos 2 menos uno es igual a
menos 3 y esto es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de 9 la raíz principal de 9 y
así obtienes este extraño resultado
menos 3 es igual a 3 que sabemos que no
es el caso y por eso sabemos que esto es
extraño pero como prometí por qué
sucedió esto y la clave es darse cuenta
de que cuando estás haciendo
manipulación algebraica algunas
operaciones son reversibles y algunas no
lo son por ejemplo si dices que amas b
es igual a c y quieres resolver para a y
restas b de ambos lados vas a obtener
que es igual a c - b y si tuvieras que
empezar con a es igual a c b podría
sumar ve a ambos lados para volver a la
ecuación original para obtener más b es
igual a c
que sumar y restar valores a ambos lados
es una operación reversible puedes
hacerlo en cualquier dirección pero
cuando estás elevando al cuadrado eso no
es cierto
y aquí elevamos al cuadrado para pasar
de este primer paso a este paso elevamos
al cuadrado y lo que veremos o lo que
quizás ya reconozcas es que esto no es
reversible sí sé que a es igual a b y
luego lo elevó al cuadrado sabemos que a
cuadrada es igual a b cuadrada pero si
vamos al revés si sabemos que a cuadrada
es igual a b cuadrada sabemos que
siempre es el caso de ya es igual a b
pues te voy a dar un ejemplo que muestra
que eso no siempre es cierto
sabemos que menos 2 al cuadrado es igual
a 2 al cuadrado pero menos 2 no es igual
a 2 de modo que eso es lo que hicimos
aquí elevamos al cuadrado en este paso y
no es reversible pudimos hacer muchas
cosas y llegamos hasta el punto en que
dijimos está bien x es igual a menos 1 o
x es igual a 7 cuartos pero no siempre
es el caso de que cuando x es igual a
menos 1 podemos revertir todo
y volver a esta ecuación original y que
12 x 1 sea igual a la raíz cuadrada de
8x y los dos lugares donde esto es
importante cuando se trata de álgebra
los dos lugares obvios son cuando estás
tratando con ecuaciones radicales porque
estás haciendo ese paso de elevar al
cuadrado
y ese paso no es reversible y otro caso
es cuando estás tratando con multiplicar
ambos lados por una variable y para
entender eso sí sabemos que a es igual a
b pero luego multiplicamos ambos lados
de esta ecuación por x así obtenemos que
x es igual a x b eso podría ser cierto
pero al revés sería necesariamente
cierto si sabemos que quizá es igual xd
es siempre cierto que a es igual a b
pues no te voy a dar un ejemplo donde
eso no es el caso que sucede cuando x es
igual a 0
sabemos que es 0 x 3 es igual a 0 x 4
pero no es el caso de que 13 a igual a 4
y esa es otra situación en la que puedes
multiplicar ambos lados de una ecuación
por una variable
es decir en esa dirección pero no es
necesariamente reversible no
necesariamente puedes volver en esa
dirección y es por eso que cuando
resuelves una ecuación muchas veces una
ecuación racional multiplicas ambos
lados de esa ecuación por una variable y
obtienes un resultado no es
necesariamente cierto que puedas tomar
ese resultado y revertirlo todo y volver
a su ecuación original es por eso que
tienes que comprobar sus soluciones
extrañas especialmente para ecuaciones
radicales y sobre todo cuando haces una
operación algebraica cómo multiplicar
ambos lados de una ecuación por una
variable o por una expresión que
involucra una variable